i'm dave rubin and joining me today
is a professor of economics at brown
university a distinguished
fellow of the american economics
association and a member
of the u.s council on foreign relations
glenn lowery welcome to the reuben
report thanks dave good to be with you
how'd i do on the bio there you have
quite an extensive bio i've got the
whole thing here i left off like 10
things that probably could have been the
lead thing
i'm a member of the american
philosophical society i'm kind of proud
of that because those are the guys that
write and the girls that write the big
books
and i don't know why they included me in
their number i haven't written any big
books but
the american philosophical society all
right there you go so before we get to
anything else i want to ask you
about that shirt because you flashed me
something right before we started
straight out of quarantine are you a
free man in a free country right now
well i have contracted been treated for
and recovered from covet 19 knock on
wood thank god
uh so uh you know yeah i mean it's a my
wife bought this shirt for me it's kind
of a play on the old uh
uh hip hop rappers straight out of
compton
so i'm straight out of quarantine and
glad to be free at last
real last well actually let's let's
start there i wasn't planning on doing
too much kind of covert related stuff to
you
but what do you what do you make out of
what has happened
in the last year related to covet and
lockdowns and then i think some of that
will probably get us into some of the
social issues of the day which is what
you're
talking about a bit more churches what
is that you're inviting me into there
dave you can say the wrong thing and get
cancelled
i mean a number thing don't worry no
nobody's been canceled because of me
yeah yeah i'm a social scientist so the
first thing i think about is what are
the kinds of studies that people are
going to do
for years assessing
what happened here and there are many
dimensions to it there's the public
health dimension to it there was a
pandemic a pathogen it spread in the
population people died
uh how effective were the various
responses to that
shutdowns masking and stuff like that
but i think there are also
political things here for example
donald trump was hated by a lot of
people they hung this around his neck
now maybe he didn't handle it as well
i don't i think i'll retract it maybe he
didn't handle it as well as he could
have handled it
okay on the other hand here was an
opportunity to save donald trump and i
think a lot of people seized on it so
one of the interesting political
questions to me is how did the partisan
character of american politics and the
role the media plays in that
affect the way that this thing was
reported but there are many many
dimensions to it so the social pressure
to conform you know have you been
vaccinated and i'm for
getting vaccinated i've been vaccinated
myself i'm not you know i'm not against
being vaccinated
uh tucker carlson whom i follow from
time to time is on the tear about the
masking stuff and there is a real
question there i mean
the government is going to tell me what
i have to put on my face
that works maybe in an absolute
emergency situation but when that
becomes a way of life
you have to start asking the question
about individual freedom and so on
so there's just many different pieces to
it that i expect will be
examined by serious people for years to
come yeah was there anything that
shocked you just about the general way
not that not the media but
just the way people sort of became so
hyper-partisan
about a virus meaning that the mask has
become sort of i'm a democrat
the non-mask is i'm a republican
something like that
sort of loosely speaking well there's
that's one aspect of it i mean
and you know some people were just
absolutely terrified i mean they
wouldn't come out of their houses they
had
their groceries they would wipe down
everything with a cloth
uh and i thought that was over the top
i thought that was excessive but then
how do we handle risk
everybody is going to react to it
differently so what i was saying to my
friends was
you know if you told me there was a one
in a thousand chance that i would die if
i stepped from my front door
i might stay inside for a week maybe two
weeks
after that i take my chances you know
what i mean so
you know don't impose your risk
preference on me
that was kind of my you know and i'm
like it takes two to tango so if i want
to have a dinner party and the people
don't want to show up what can i do
uh but i i did feel that there was a lot
of over-the-top
uh kind of overreaction the school's
staying close to what now i'm not an
expert on the data about school closings
but my colleague emily oster
is at brown university's economics
department look her up
she had a piece of the new yorker about
this she is next she's a liberal she's a
liberal
and they just tried to tear her apart
because she said
school should open up because she said
the data don't justify keeping the kids
away from the classroom you're doing
more harm than you're doing good
the cure is worse than the disease where
did i hear that before
she said it she said and they tried to
take her head off
so you know it was really really a
very interesting and very pathological
situation from the way in which we made
decisions as a society
i think politics fear panic
uh group think you know these were these
were all at play
what do you consider yourself
politically do you specifically say
i'm this i'm that on the other thing
because when i'm listening to you i
sense a little bit of everything which
by the way
that's probably how most people really
are we just get hung up on the label
okay
so i'm registered independent
uh i don't tell people how i vote what i
was telling them during last year's
presidential election is
of course i voted for biden what else
would you expect me to say and then i'd
laugh and i'd say
i can't say anything else you still
don't know who i voted for if i tell you
i voted for biden because if i voted for
the other guy
i'd never tell you i voted for but i'm a
conservative
i think i just have to admit that now
you know on a number of different
dimensions
i'm an economist and i lean neo-liberal
i lean toward open markets and free
trade and
letting the prices do their work i i
don't like the green new deal because
these people want to absolutely run our
economy on behalf of their
vision about how the future should look
and that that that terrifies me i think
taxes are
generally speaking too high i think
regulation
can go often does go over the top
uh and impedes uh uh impedes our
prosperity
i think the way forward has been shown
by capitalism
with a c capitalism not with a k
etc so you know that makes me somewhat
of a conservative
i write a lot about racial issues and
i'm cutting against the grain there
i think the country has lost its mind
with this diversity and inclusion stuff
i'm not a big fan of affirmative action
i think reparations would be an absolute
disaster for this country as well as for
african americans we could talk about it
but so so they call me a conservative
and i'm not fighting with them about it
yeah i i hear you and i think what you
just said right there sums up
what most of my audience probably is at
some level whether you know some are
maybe a little more libertarian or a
little
more traditionally conservative or
whatever it is but you just gave me a
great
sort of lead on everything else i want
to talk about because
uh one of the things that i want to talk
about is we hear this phrase systemic
racism all the time and i've heard you
talk about this i've read some of your
stuff on this in some ways we're just
not all talking about
the same thing when we say the phrase
systemic racism so can you lay out
maybe what you believe it to mean versus
what you think some other people think
it means okay in the simplest terms
here's what i think people are saying
they're saying back in the old days of
the civil rights movement civil rights
act of 1964 martin luther king and all
of that
the issue was racist treatment unequal
treatment of people discrimination and
housing and
jobs and credit markets and so on blacks
weren't treated the same they were
discriminated against
and the goal was equal treatment which
is why king is there saying
uh i have a dream that my kids will be
judged by the content of their character
he doesn't want him discriminated
against he doesn't want him kept from
voting because they're black
he doesn't want him kept from shopping
because they're black he wants them to
be treated like anybody else that's the
old school thing
systemic racism is declaring there to be
a new day
because guess what we pretty much have
solved the discrimination problem
not completely but just about as
completely as you could solve it in a
free society
every state has an equal employment
opportunity commission there's a ton of
lawsuits that you can bring against your
employer if you think you're not being
treated fairly
god help a retailer if he actually does
discriminate and charge a different
price to a black customer
right because so which we would all be
against just to be yeah
that bit has been solved yeah but the
disparities are still there
okay blacks are overrepresented amongst
the incarcerated
underrepresented amongst the students at
a fancy college uh have lower wealth
holdings etc etc so the disparities are
there
but the account of the disparities that
black person was discriminated against
is no longer very uh effective as an
explanation
so people are calling on larger forces
not
personal one-on-one historical forces
i mean here's an example new orleans
floods
black people on average live at lower uh
level sea level
so they get flooded worse they get
flooded worse because they're poor
they get flooded whereas maybe because
in the history of new orleans i don't
know anything about it specifically but
this is just a hypothetical
they were discriminated against and the
high ground housing wasn't as easily
those neighborhoods weren't the re real
estate agents didn't show them whatever
whatever
they got worse jobs you know etc so
they're on the low line so then the
flood comes and they discriminate
now some of us would think you know
that's an unfortunate act of nature and
then you know
just like if a pandemic comes and you
got more comorbidities and pre-existing
conditions you're going to
get a harder hit but it's not an act of
racism
a person might say but the systemic
racism people want to say oh no no no
it is an act of racism you see that
disparity
the history of race in america is what
has made that disparity happen
then they have their story in this case
uh the blacks are in the low-lying
neighborhoods in
new orleans because of discrimination in
the past and racism
and so that's their story mass
incarceration is racist
why because well the drug laws are
what they are and they wouldn't be what
they are if the people who were being
locked up were
mostly white people and not they have
their accounts they're not enough blacks
at caltech
why because of systemic racism in the
education system and so on
so it's an effort to explain disparities
in the absence of individual racist
discriminatory acts that's how i
understand it
so i'm i'm guessing well of course you
know of and probably know thomas all but
the book discrimination verse
disparities
i mean he goes into this a lot so what
do we do about the disparity
stuff for those that understand what
you're saying that are saying okay the
system's not racist meaning there are no
racist laws against black people but
that want to acknowledge
that there that these disparities exist
where do you start
with the disparities because we seem to
we can't even get there
well if you follow thomas soul i do know
him not that well although i've just
joined the
as a senior fellow at the hoover
institution so i'm going to get to know
him better i'll add that to the bio for
next time
i i just signed on i haven't even been
accepted on the uh on the campus yet but
but uh i'm looking forward to it but but
if you follow thomas soul he would say
it's a fool's errand to think that
you're ever going to get rid of all the
disparities
he would say look at the ethnic chinese
in indonesia and the philippines and
southeast asia he said look at them
they they're business people they they
are wealthier they
are better educated they're over he
would say look at the sing elise and the
and the uh tamil in sri lanka he would
say
look at the lebanese and west africa he
would say look at the jews pretty much
everywhere he would you know he would
say
there is no absence of disparity
the story of ethnic history is disparity
so if you set for yourself the goal of
getting rid of disparity
all right this puts it a little sharply
but i think it's not inaccurate
you're buying into tyranny because the
only way to get rid of disparity is to
force things to be equal when the
natural state of affairs would not have
things be equal
what would getting rid of disparity in
the nba mean or the nfl
i mean well we know what it would mean
it would mean a lot of chinese point
guards
and it would be a lot less interest
that's a cheap shot i know i mean that
was easy for me to say you're going to
my waitress man i got a basketball right
behind me
45 with the blown out acl in my left
knee but that's what i'd rather be doing
than this
oh okay you were good in your day yeah
all right but but so saul would say
don't expect that there is not going to
be disparities
um i would i would agree with that but i
would go further
i don't think that uh if i don't like
disparities get busy this is what i want
to say to
to my fellow african americans you don't
like the disparities you don't like the
wealth gap start a business
uh you don't think there's enough black
engineers okay let's study some calculus
let's get some
kids together we do it on the summer
we'll have a summer camp and we'll do a
boot camp on calculus
kid that can do the integral equation
fastness or get a star on this thing and
whatever whatever all right get busy uh
disparities don't have to be destiny
just because there's a disparity doesn't
mean that we have to accept it as given
if indeed we
we want better for ourselves and for our
people but don't be
looking outside of the community for
society or
white people or whatever to solve that
problem for you
especially when our families are in
disarray
especially when the behavior of some
people a few in our communities makes
life absolutely impossible for anybody
else
to function there because of the
violence and the chaotic behavior and
whatnot
especially when the tv can be turned off
and the kid could be directed to do his
homework or hers
that's a part of the parental
responsibility etc etc
i i don't mean to be putting people down
i just mean to say
our fate this is my argument is
substantially
within our own hands so if you don't
like the disparities get busy
disparities aren't destiny that that's a
title for a book right there
you you got that that's the that's the
next book you gotta write
um within all that you're you're talking
about the family and then you know
seoul also talks about how when the
welfare state really kicked in in the
70s that in essence it blew apart
the black family um but even talking
about this
people people will not be kind
yeah well you got two things going you
got feminism
so what i mean is you have a revolution
in political
social attitudes around the roles of
women and about the
the uh sort of legitimacy of
conventional two-parent arrangements and
stuff like that so
i don't want to just put it all on the
women those sexual morality ideas have
changed you know gay rights and stuff
like that i mean it's a different world
than it was 50 years ago
and that has worked against i think the
uh the job of
mending the black family i put it in
those turns people will get upset
but what i mean is if 70 of
kids babies born to a black woman are
born to a woman without a husband this
is not
a healthy state of affairs for the
community
that has consequences in terms of the
human development
of those youngsters boys need fathers
girls need fathers too
adolescent boys with the testosterone
flowing need discipline they need
fathers they need examples of what it
means to live
rightly as a man in the world in the
absence of that you're going to get the
kind of chaos that you're seeing
so you've got that that the social
liberals the
the people who want to rewrite the rules
will object to invoking tradition
in this context the other piece you've
got is uh
we had a war on poverty and poverty won
that that would be
you know that's what charles murray said
in that classic book of his losing
ground
that's what tom asola is saying when he
points out the ill effects of the
welfare state
and on the other side of that is the
democratic party and the liberal
political establishment and whatnot who
believe
uh that the transfers from the welfare
state can do no harm
you know there are no incentive problems
uh now if you tell a woman that you know
she can get by on a not it's not a good
living welfare is not a good living
but it is money coming from the state
and you think that that doesn't affect
her behavior
well you know again i'm an economist of
course it does affect her behavior
uh so i i don't know that i wanted to
clear
war on medicaid or food stamps these are
established programs there are
hundreds of billions of dollars going
out the federal door
but there are families that need these
benefits i think we've
gone far enough down this road now that
it's hard to imagine going back
but uh if as a historical analysis i
think
part of the weight has to be laid at the
feet of weight of
the structure of african-american family
life in the year 2021
has to be laid at the feet of those who
uh
who didn't listen uh when they were
warned about
the ill effects of transfer programs on
the incentives that people had
so so yeah yeah so speaking of of those
who didn't listen you mentioned the
social liberals now i'm guessing at
brown university politically you
are an outsider you're surrounded by a
lot of liberals although
i wouldn't say they're old school
liberals at this point you're probably
surrounded really by
a bunch of leftists but do you do you
find that some of your
old school socially liberal say
classical liberal colleagues if any
remain
kind of on the dl are like yeah glenn
you're right about all this stuff but
you know you know i don't want them
showing up at my house
yes uh not quite those words
but pretty much that attitude a lot of
people
i mean there's a lot of different stuff
going on some people are religious and
they're in the closet
that they they actually believe in god
they pray you know they read the bible
and they won't and they won't talk about
it
some people have misgivings they're not
sure but they know that the wind is
blowing so strong in the other direction
but i'll tell you i've been encouraged
by some of my students
here at brown which is notorious for
being an ultra liberal bastion and
certainly we've got plenty of that
but there are students around here who
are hungry for something
different and i i found them you know
coming to some of my classes and coming
around to talk to me privately
uh i'm not saying that they would have
voted for donald trump they would have
never done that
you know i'm not saying that they're
pro-life they're not they're pro-choice
they're pro-gay marriage and all that
kind of stuff but but i am saying that
they find some of the
uh concerns that i've i've been
expressing around
these issues to to resonate with them
and some of them are religious
and they will come and and they will say
and i must say
i'm not myself personally a professing
christian at this point in my life
i used to be very strongly i was
baptized at the age of 40.
uh it's a long story i'll tell it in my
memoir stay tuned
but but i'm open to people who
are uh who are overt about expressing
their faith and i have deep respect
for uh this challenge that we all face
as uh uh sentient beings
of contemplating the ultimate questions
of existence
uh and there are no easy answers to
those ultimate questions
so i find that in some of my students
i'm just saying brown is not one thing
we have a reputation deservedly so
but it's a complicated and interesting
community here and and i do find like
minds
uh both amongst my colleagues and and
students yeah you know even though i'll
let you save that story for your memoir
but
do you find that that there is some sort
of spiritual
awakening i i've sort of sensed that
because
the the progressive movement has just
become this secularism on steroids
government everything
monster that an awful lot of people and
i would include myself in this who are
not traditionally religious
are finding answers in different ways
well i hope that's right i can't you
know i just gave you my report about
what's going on here at brown i can't
speak beyond that but
uh i hope that's right yeah interesting
um all right so let's move on to some of
the other things well first off
according to my paperwork here you're
black is that is that
last time i checked i'm like i was born
in chicago 1948
on the south side my mother and father
were also born in chicago
and they were black i'm black okay so as
a black man that's a professor at a
liberal university i i unfortunately end
up having to ask
all of my my black guests or i would
rather say guests who happen to be black
that are doing something sort of similar
to what you're doing
can you just talk a little bit about the
type of treatment you get not from some
of the good students but just sort of
you know from the say anti-racist crowd
because
they're not that thrilled with you
i you know i'm probably the wrong guy to
ask i mean i'm 72 years old
okay i know it doesn't show but it's
true born in 1948
so i'm a i'm a senior member of the
community i've been around for a long
time i'm a known quantity
uh i you know i have the various
accolades that i have i've had a
distinguished career as a research
economist
i don't think people really tell me
what they think or react to me uh
it may be certain deference to my
position and to my senior
status uh it may be out of respect for
my for my
academic accomplishments i hold a chair
here at brown etcetera
i think they make whisper uh out of my
earshot
this or that but but i don't feel the
chill
now kofi kovid has had an impact here
because we're not coming face to face
we're meeting through zoom and skype and
such
and this last year has been a year in
which some of my
more conservative ideas especially about
race and
diversity and equity have come to a head
because of the
reckoning about race in the aftermath of
george floyd and all of that
i've written pieces that have gotten a
lot of positive play in
conservative quarters which i'm sure
some of my colleagues despise
but i'm not seeing them around the lunch
table at the faculty club so that they
can
you know convey their contempt for me
with their glare or their whatever
so i so i i don't know about the last
year
but before that i would say it was kind
of like a gentleman's agreement
they you know glenn's glenn is a
curmudgeon
glenn is glenn yeah that's where he's
coming from
he's not a bad guy he's all screwed up
about this stuff but that's all right
we'll still invite him to dinner you
know
and i don't know what's going to happen
once we get back to uh business as usual
we'll see
it's kind of funny idea for a short
story a conservative professor who
because of lockdowns can feel more
emboldened because the colleagues aren't
going to
sneer at him at the commissary or
something you know
somebody ought to be working on that
story somebody should be
do you sense there's anything left i
mean i get you're not a democrat
i haven't heard you say you're a
republican but i get you're not a
democrat i'm a registered independent
who's you know
playing both sides of the street so to
speak but i'm not very happy with where
the democrats are right yeah i mean do
you sen is there anything
left there that is in line with the
ideas that you believe in that you think
is in line with the ideas of martin
luther king
the democrats are nothing without the
black voting 95
90 for their candidates they would lose
control of everything without the sub
fine would be present today with if
james clyburn were not able to corral
enough black votes in south carolina's
democratic primary
to get him out of the hole um so
here's what i see i'm not a professional
political scientist so you can take it
for what it's worth
they're buying black votes by waving a
bloody shirt of racism
that's what they're doing they're
selling this idea
that george floyd's death was yet one of
another of another of another
racist state killing of black people
there's open season as ben krupp says in
the title of his book
on black people not black people be
afraid be afraid be very afraid
white racists are coming to get you
they're in your police department
they're right around the corner and we
are the only thing between you
and a noose around your neck that's what
they're saying it's not the new gym
the georgia voting integrity law is not
just jim crow it's jim
eagle they they want to put you all in
chains that's a quote from
president joseph button they want to put
y'all back in chains
okay so if black people i speak now to
african americans if you happen to be
watching the dave
dave rubin report if you fall for this
we're fools if we fall for this
we are fools we're being led around with
a ring
through our noses
so they show nothing but contempt for
black people
i'm talking about joseph r biden now
i'm with you i know my audience is with
you and i think
i think actually truly i think most of
america is with you we
we just don't know where the brave
voices are i think that's part of the
problem i mean you're one of them but i
think that
we're living in this in this bravery
deficit right now
these issues the racial conflict coming
out of slavery
threatened the existence of the republic
600
000 people in the country of 30 million
were slaughtered on the battlefields of
the civil war
the consequence of which was the
emancipation of the african slaves
here we are now 150 years later and the
descendants of those slaves
are citizens of the freest richest and
most powerful republic
in the history of the world man glenn
you want to run for president i got it
you're 72 but come on
come on that's young for a president
these days
thanks i appreciate that uh that's
that's not the burden i was thinking
about
taking up right now i was looking for
the beach i was looking to put my feet
up man
fair enough fair enough um well can you
can you paint away or do you see a way
out of this i think a lot of people sort
of think we're just
we're just in this endless descent we
can we can address the things that
you've addressed we could say no you
guys are wrong because we have to talk
about
disparities instead of discrimination we
have to define things properly
but i think a lot of people think oh we
we just can't
stop this force
i don't know how it stops to be honest
with you i feel like i'm spitting in the
wind
my my little humble efforts with john
mcwhorter we have a podcast the glenn
show and we talk about these things and
whatnot
that's at patreon.com forward slash glen
show two ends one word
uh you know we'll link to it but i gotta
get you on locals that's a different
topic
oh okay but but in any case man i i i
think we had a chance with the
presidency of barack obama
to really change the conversation and
that he let us down
uh you we can talk about the presidency
of barack obama it is many many things
it's not just this but on this portfolio
if i had a son he looked like trayvon he
shouldn't have said that
should have said my friend against the
police act that stupidly we could go
through all these things
he shouldn't have made al sharpton uh
200 times visiting the white house
ambassador to black america
from his administration he shouldn't
have done that he should have stood for
law and order when baltimore was burning
down when ferguson missouri was burning
down instead of splitting the difference
and saying
they have legitimate grievances of
course they have legitimate grievances
but it doesn't rise to the level of
arson
and assault on police officers and
looting that's unforgivable that's
that cannot be tolerated i don't care
what their grievances are and he should
have said so
he should have turned to black america
as he tried to do a little bit during
the campaign but he
beat a retreat from it and said yeah
there's racism but you know what we need
to pull up our socks
he could have found a better way of
saying it he could have found an obama
ass
way of saying it we need to stand up
straight with our shoulders back as
jordan peterson
could say we need to take care of our
kids we need to get busy
racism is not the first or the second or
the third issue
confronting us he could have said that
he could have shut up
some of these people like tana hasikots
instead he invites them for cozy talks
uh etc shut him up by saying
my occupying this office
commander-in-chief of the most powerful
military on the planet
the agenda center for this great
republic of 325 million people
gives the lie to your talk about uh
oppressive denial of the integrity of
black bodies
he said it in 2004 barack obama did he
said it's in my very dna
he's black and he's white we all are
metaphorically speaking there's only one
people
here the american people there's only
one people
here uh for a variety of reasons
president obama
elected and it's not an easy job it's a
hard job that's why i don't want it
thanks anyway dave
for a variety of reasons he elected not
to take that one on and he's the only
person who could have taken it on
he's the only person who could have sat
in the white house
you saw what happened when trump tried
to order out the national guard or
whatever it was he tried to do to deal
you know and everybody goes ballistic
and it's all racist and whatnot like
obama is the only person who could have
changed that conversation
by putting his racial identity and his
civic responsibility on the line
not as a fealty to the black victim
narrative
but as an affirmation of the
possibilities of the country
now it's easy for me to say this i know
but that's what i
see when i look at it in retrospect an
opportunity was missed between 2009
and 2017 uh and where we are now
i mean i heard michelle obama the former
first lady
say to gail king at cbs morning news the
other day
that she worried that her daughter sasha
and malia might be set upon by
wrong police officers because they're
black and they might be mistaken for
somebody
and i have to that i have to say this i
mean i said this in my podcast i said to
you
first of all it's false it's false you
got to get past the secret service to
get to those kids
she knows its fault secondly she knows
that what she said
is untrue so what is she doing she's
playing you negroes she's
playing you she's enacting
a trope a narrative on
in the surface of a political program
which is to keep you on the reservation
afraid that the boogeyman racist is
going to come and get your children
she's not worried about her children
being harassed by on martha's vineyard
by uh uh a a cop because they're black
so instead of pushing
against this narrative which is
comforting
it is a comfortable place to be if
you're black i'm a victim
they wouldn't let me get the nobel prize
because i was black i'm an economist i'm
a damn good economist
i want the nobel prize i want the nobel
prize they wouldn't let me have it
because i'm playing
okay that that is getting old
but we need our leaders i'm talking
about african-american leaders
to point away for a point away from that
and
they're not doing it so let's let's
shift a little bit back to the academic
part of this because
related to all of this is the fact that
academic standards are basically being
obliterated right now
in the name of equity in terms of
testing
in terms of you know what's happening at
harvard where they're actually punishing
asian students at the admissions level
that must
putting aside the racial part just as an
academic as someone at a place of higher
education that that must drive you crazy
well i'm against it i signed on to the
uh
amicus brief that some economists uh put
together
to support the asians in their lawsuit
against harvard because i
i disagree with that policy
but many of us here in the academy are
full score behind
behind this stuff
it breaks my heart to be honest with you
because it's an
invitation to mediocrity and and
you know it's it's a kind of bluff and a
shell game
here let me just be clear about what i'm
talking about at the very most exclusive
venues of intellectual
labor like at a princeton university or
a brown university
or an mit or a cal tech the stuff is
really hard and not everybody can do it
well
it's hard it's hard reading uh plato
and figuring out what he was talking
about it's hard doing uh physics
it's hard doing advanced mathematics and
chemistry and other stem stuff like that
that stuff is difficult
med school is hard law school is hard it
requires
real intellectual mastery in order to be
done
effectively now unfortunately
a proportionate number of
african-americans have not achieved that
mastery
now we can go into the reasons why
history has not been entirely kind to
african americans
there's blame enough to go around why
but the fact of the matter is
a proportionate number relative to
population of blacks so we're fewer
in the venues where the intellectual
work is difficult
now there are two things you can do in
the face of that
one of them is to lower the standards so
that you can increase the representation
of african americans and call that
inclusion
the other is to grasp the nettle
bite the bullet whatever metaphor you
want face up
to the developmental deficiencies
and address them and i mean address them
from
infancy okay now this this is not
laissez-faire i'm not saying there could
be no government program i'm not saying
don't have any education don't have any
head start
don't have any summer program don't
whatever
we can talk about what the things are
that need to be done but can we first
understand what the problem is if our
kids are testing poorly
it's because they don't know the
material
okay if an asian kid from a poor family
living in a two-room apartment with
four siblings can ace the test our kids
can do it too
anybody who doesn't think so is a racist
they have the racism of the bigotry of
low expectation about black
you write us off you think we're
defeated by history
you think we're infants that that we
can't actually perform
we can perform we need to do the work
give us an opportunity confront the
deficits redress them keep the level of
playing field
don't lower the bar for us and we'll
measure up in the fullness of time it
may not happen tomorrow
and it may not happen the next day but
it'll happen in the fullness of time
i say this as a matter of faith so
i think we made the wrong choice now i
can understand in 1970 with all the
rabble rousing and whatnot
and the universities had to meet the
protest halfway and whatnot and they did
what they did
but we're now in the year 2021 we're a
half
century past that and we're we're laying
down a predicate for how it is that we
go forward and this
no it's not equality it's equity
bunk is a surrender
in the face of the problem that we face
the problem is
develop black people so that
proportionately more of us
exhibit the mastery requisite to being
uh successful in these uh competitive
venues did you see what happened
i ramble a bit but thank you for giving
me the time you see what happened at the
georgetown law center the georgetown law
center
this brouhaha from uh a few months ago
uh instructor into a hot mic not knowing
that she was being recorded
allowed us how the poor performers in
her class at the clustering at the
bottom were very disproportionately
black
she said it upset her she didn't know
what to do about it but the black kids
were not doing well
do you know what happened when it was
revealed that she had said this
they defined georgetown law as a racist
institution
the students demanded and the dean
acceded to the demand that this
professor be fired
white professors were called upon to get
together and issue a statement on behalf
of their
white privilege taking responsibility
for the poor performance of the black
students in the law class
now here's what i know contracts
constitutional law torts
civil procedure this is what you study
in law school that stuff is hard man
that that stuff will make your head hurt
those big casebooks that you see people
carrying around and stuff like that
writing an effective legal argument
is a real skill
what the professor was reporting is that
the black kids at georgetown this is
georgetown this is one of the elite law
schools on the planet
disproportionately don't have that skill
now you would have thought that the
administration being informed of that
would slap their foreheads and says oh
my god let's do something to make sure
that our
youngsters who are of color have the
skill no
no they retreat behind this
institutional racism stuff
and it's patronizing and condescending
to blacks to do it because what you're
really saying is we don't think you're
ever going to be able to cut it we'll
cover for you it's okay
so so as a numbers guy and as an
economist have you ever seen an instance
where equity actually raises anyone or
is it
is it literally always that the way we
get equity is that you're bringing
down a certain class does it ever do
this other thing
well i i'm not sure how to answer that
i'm sure i could find
examples where
um if i if i did a little bit of
leveling and and evening early on
the the opportunities that i generated
for kids you know would give them a
chance you know
to show what they can do and they might
not otherwise be able to get in or
whatever but i'm hard-pressed
i'm hard-pressed to actually come up
with an example so i'll just answer
no you definitely can't be president
because you forthrightly answered a
question that you weren't totally sure
of the answer
you mentioned uh you mentioned
reparations before and about
maybe about four months ago or so
suddenly it was a very hot conversation
now there's a whole bunch of other stuff
going on
so it seems to have tempered down a
little bit but we know it's going to
come back
into the equation uh you're against
reparations
uh can you can you explain why i mean i
think it's a clear through line
to everything we've discussed but i want
to let you answer well it's certainly
related to what i've been saying but
don't do that to our country don't don't
do that to our countries
here so let's be specific you know about
the japanese who were interred
by the roosevelt administration in the
second world war and they lost their
property and their businesses and it was
a horrible thing their civil liberties
these were citizens some of the many of
the most of them
so ronald reagan signed into law
and i think george herbert walker bush
presided over the administration
of a a statute that recognized the harm
apologized to those people and paid them
reparations
they got twenty thousand ahead there was
eighty thousand of them
eighty thousand people twenty thousand
dollars ahead that's 1.6 billion dollars
and the people who got paid were the
ones who got dispossessed
not their children not their
grandchildren not their cousins right
20 000 ahead 80 000 people 1.6 billion
dollars
so we can do that and we should have
done it
now you take african americans we're 40
million
i don't know what 40 acres in a mule
comes to in the current day but they
tell me it's in the tens of thousands of
dollars so let's just say a hundred
thousand dollars to be
on this okay that's four
trillion dollars
with a t
the entire japanese got 1.6 billion
80 000 of them these people are talking
about
trillions of dollars being in one way or
another transferred to americans who are
black
that's a social security scale
enactment of public distribution
based on the race of the citizen
that's south africa-esque we don't want
that for our country i i don't say that
as a black man i say that as an american
we don't want that for our country
that's not the way we do this
now if we're concerned about people who
are disadvantaged
we can direct ourselves to their
disadvantage by the way i don't
really see an argument for overlooking a
disadvantaged white person on my way to
helping a disadvantaged black person
so what i think the advocates of
reparations should do easy for me to say
they're not listening to me
for advice is if they want to see more
money spent on schools if they want to
see more money spent on welfare if they
want to see more money spent on
education
or whatever on housing on health care
uh put the weight of their advocacy
behind whatever the progressive
political program is that they think is
going to deliver that for themselves i
might not support every uh
letter of it but that's neither here nor
there that's for the country
so that's one argument i have against
reparations please don't do that to my
country
we're already divided enough by race but
there's another argument that i have
that i think is just as important which
is
the problems besetting the black poor
are not going to go away
when you enact uh some kind of statute
like this
i'm talking about the out of wind like
burst i'm talking about the single
parent families i'm talking about the
poor
reading and math skills i'm talking
about the low work habits i'm talking
about the number of people involved in
the criminal activity the people who are
in the prisons
and so forth and so on there's going to
continue to be an issue in detroit
cleveland st
louis south side west side of chicago
etc and many many other places besides
in this country
if you sit down at a bargaining table
with america and cut a deal you cut a
side deal with america
for blacks on behalf of that and you get
paid whatever you get
that commodifies your claim on the
country
and discharges the obligation now you're
on your own
next time around people will rightly be
able to say to you don't come to me with
your
bellyaching about this or about that you
have been paid
why would we do that just from a purely
tactical point of view that's not that's
not a good play
so it's bad for the country and at the
end of the day even though it may not be
apparent
it's also bad for black people in my
opinion can i toss in one more i'd love
to know what you think about this that
it also sort of ignores human psychology
which is that even if you did the four
trillion and everyone gets a hundred
grand that the progresses
of tomorrow will tell the people who
accept the money you sold us
out for that money because of what you
just laid out there
that most likely the problems don't go
away and then suddenly the progressives
of 2040 will say
well either we want more or the
generation before us
was just part of the evil corrupt system
or something like that
yeah that's probably right and it's
probably
the case that uh they'll be able to get
something out of that if
the politics of the current day is still
uh going on i mean notwithstanding the
fact that you've been paid that you'd
still be able to
to milk the system for something based
on
on on that kind of an argument i don't
know i can't think that far ahead dave
do you get sick of talking about the the
race thing because i don't know how much
you know about me specifically but
i was a progressive i was a lefty you
know and then really what there were
a few things that woke me up but i would
say the one thing that i really shifted
on was libertarian economics
talking to thomas all and some of the
other great libertarian and conservative
economists um so i could talk to you
about
economy the economy all day long and
that would be great but of course we
gotta
do some of this stuff do you ever just
you know when when you're talking
to john on the podcast do you ever just
get sick of having to do that
thing yeah in fact john and i have
talked about it in the archives
somewhere we've had a couple episodes
where we just reflected on
why don't we get out of the race
business he's a linguist and a very he's
a very
talented and accomplished professor of
linguistics
writes books about the stuff i'm a
technical economist i have
the accolades to show and so forth and
so on and we could live perfectly fine
quiet lives just doing our thing
uh so yeah we've talked about it i even
tried it
uh back back in the day back when i was
a
i was a reagan republican and i was on
my way to
to washington and i ended up getting
caught in a in a scandal with a
extramarital affair and i got accused of
assaulting a woman which i did not do
but it was
it was the end of my public career for
that uh for that period
and i said ah let me get out of the race
business let me go back and i published
three papers in the american economic
review
in one year which is virtually an
unprecedented accomplishment
uh because i i put my head down and just
started doing my research
it lasted for maybe three or four years
and the next thing you knew
the events of the day kept pulling me
back and pulling me back and i finally
just stopped fighting it i think this is
part of my calling it's not the whole
thing but it's a part of it
uh i'm doing some stuff that relatively
few people
will slash can do and it's important i
think it's important
so you know i've kind of acquiesced to
that being
a part of my role but i like reading
novels you know and
and philosophy and history and whatnot
this is not my whole life but it is what
i'm
it's the beat that i'm covering right
now so i got one
one more for you and i think i know the
answer already because you're saying a
lot of this with a smile on your face
and just sort of your general demeanor
but
are you hopeful that we can get through
this thing and get back to some of the
principles that you've talked about here
that you think are the right guiding
principles for this country
you think we can get through this i i
don't know i
i i alternate sometimes i'm very
pessimistic what's happening in our
schools is absolutely fundamental i'm
talking about k-12
i'm saying what we're teaching kids the
16-19 project
scared the bejesus out of me that's the
new york times
that's a rewriting of american history
centering it on the fact of slavery
and i don't mind of course that we would
teach our kids about the history of
slavery in this country
but 1776 1787 the constitution being
ratified
man that is a world historic creation of
a government
under the ideas of the enlightenment
with real institutions that have
worked for centuries and been a beacon
to the world
you don't put 1619 next to 1776 and call
it a draw
that that's throwing away the baby with
the bath water
that's a disaster if that kind of idea
gets in the heads of too many of our
young people
so i think the jury is out and i think
the battlefield is k-12 education
critical race theory in the schools now
there is free speech
we we could fight about creation science
we could fight about sex education in
the school so i guess we're going to
have to fight about this too
but to me that's ground zero glenn
it's been a pleasure this was this was
overdue i thank you for taking the time
my pleasure dave if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe
and click the notification bell